bonsoir à tous et ce que vous êtes chaud
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depardon j'ai oublié que je faisais pas
un spectacle
j'espère quand même que vous allez bien
alors je vais rapidement me présenter
pour qu'on soit plus à l'aise vous et
moi
je m'appelle anthony crette
je mesure 1 mètre 70 2 pour 61 kg de
muscles essentiellement et j'aime
beaucoup les carbonara ainsi que les
projecteurs led de préférence ce qui
bouge comme ceci mais j'ai également une
autre passion et c'est l'humour que ce
soit sur scène ou à l'écran alors
j'aurais pu faire tout mon passage sur
les carbonara mais j'ai préféré vous
transmettre mon idée grâce à cette
dernière passion qu'est l'humour
l'idée en question est
la liberté est propre à chacun est
proportionnelle à la zone de confort
ouais je sors souvent des phrases comme
ça en impro
j'ai pas du tout fait 13 heures pour
trouver la formulation
alors pour les autodidactes qui ont
compris tout de suite bravo les autres
ne vous inquiétez pas je vais tout
expliquer c'est comme s'ils seront
rouges
représentait ma zone de confort là où je
me sens bien mes petites habitudes que
je ne veux pas chamboulé et tout autour
la
grèce a fait peur
alors si la taille de ma zone me
convient bien j'ai la liberté qu'il me
faut
comme dit dans ma super phrase cela
dépend de chaque personne mais si je me
sens trop à l'étroit et que j'ose pas en
sortir
on ne se sent pas libre mais pas de
panique j'ai découvert que non seulement
on pouvait sortir de cette zone et en
plus la grandir vous verrez ce
fantastique alors pour mieux illustrer
tout ça je vais prendre mon exemple de
vie étant donné que celui que je connais
le mieux donc on va faire un petit
retour dans le temps
en été 2010 est je participe à un camp
musical et là je suis enrôlé dans la
petite équipe de présentation du concert
de fin de semaine j'ai jamais fait ça
mais voilà je fais un mini sketchs entre
deux morceaux et ça me plaît assez sans
le savoir j'avais déjà fait un pas en
dehors de ma zone de confort
à la fin du concert une personne de ma
commune en charge de la culture vient me
voir pour me proposer d'animer une
soirée en fin d'année
c'est une soirée locale de jeunes
talents alors encore une fois j'accepte
et je me mets à préparer ça sauf que là
c'est tout de suite plus compliqué
j'ai beaucoup plus de temps à être sur
scène et je sais pas comment m'y prendre
heureusement qu'il ya mes parents qui
m'aident dans ce projet sinon j'étais
foutu mais voilà je les fais on a créé
des personnages et j'ai eu plein de bons
retours
encore une fois j'avais fait un pas en
dehors de ma zone et puis vient
là je suis en 0 3e du cycle pour les
anciens et on nous demande d'élaborer un
projet personnel
alors moi en toute sérénité je me suis
dit que j'allais créer un spectacle
complet vu l'immense expérience que
j'avais acquis ce jusque là pas de
soucis un j'écris de trois blagues le
soir après l'école
j'invite plein de gens ils viennent dans
une seule comme celle ci par exemple et
puis je prévois de la viande sachets
pour la sortie et puis c'est tout bon
alors là mes parents et mes profs essaye
de me dire écoute anthony s'est pas à
prendre à la légère
réfléchit bien il ya beaucoup de travail
alors ça m'a quand même beaucoup fait
réfléchir et c'est pour ça que je me
suis dit on y va ça peut pas être si
terrible
alors je me suis lancé
à la base avec un copain musicien pour
faire un spectacle humour musique mais
on n'a pas réussi à mettre ça en place
et je me suis retrouvé seul et là je me
suis dit que j'étais un homme mort je
m'étais peut-être un peu trop éloigné de
ma petite zone confortable
je galère est clairement j'ai passé des
nuits blanches pour tenter de penser à
tout la mise en scène l'endroit où le
faire le matériel technique les
techniciens et surtout les speechs
aucune idée et je savais pas comment
faire c'est tellement difficile de
s'imaginer les réactions du public quand
tu es tout seul devant ta feuille
alors ne pensez pas que les problèmes se
sont réglés avec l'avancement du projet
on arrive deux jours avant le spectacle
je ne sais toujours pas mon texte et il
me manque beaucoup trop d'heures de
sommeil et ses pendants de répétition
que 1 des copains que j'avais engagé
pour la technique m'a dit ça ce que je
disais en devenir mon conseil pour qu'il
ne stresse pas c'était
respecter a filmé la vie continue
alors ça ne m'a pas du tout rassuré
mais c'était très juste ma vie n'allait
pas s'effondrer si je me loupe est je
pouvais pas être parfait c'était une
première mais moi je m'imaginais déjà en
sortant de chez moi des gens qui
m'attendent avec des tomates gros du
gros nuls
j'exagère un petit peu mais c'est ce que
j'avais dans la tête
et puis vient le jour j
19 mai 2010huit cinq mois de réflexion
et de travail qui vont se concrétiser en
une heure la pression est à son comble
le public meurt d'impatience
mes parents ne savent pas encore s'ils
vont devoir me renier
alors j'arrête le suspense tout s'est
bien passé
c'était top sinon je serai dans ma cave
depuis trois ans tonne me cacher
aulas pour l'historique des événements
c'est seulement plus tard que j'ai
rencontré quelqu'un de très inspirants
qui a mis des mots sur ce concept de
zone de confort
et qui m'a fait comprendre les bénéfices
de continuer à en sortir
parce que dans tout le parcours que je
viens de vous expliquer à chaque fois je
suis sorti de ma zone de confort par
inconscience totale
mais voilà je suis pas sûr que j'aurais
écrit un one man show si je mettais
réellement rendu compte de ce que ça
représentait mais je les fais et c'est
une des plus belle chose qui me soit
arrivée dans la vie j'ai pu le jouer une
dizaine de fois alors qu'initialement je
pensais le faire qu'une seule fois pour
le projet personnel et surtout j'ai pu
découvrir ma passion et mon rêve de
devenir humoriste
alors vous vous dites peut-être
que vous n'avez pas envie de faire un
one man show et c'est tout à fait normal
d'ailleurs je vous le déconseille après
ça fait trop de concurrence
mais blague à part ce concept fonctionne
pour tous les domaines de la vie au
travail dans vos relations sociales ou
encore pour réaliser votre rêve
moi j'ai fait un immense pas dehors de
ma zone mais c'est pas non plus le but
vous pouvez faire un petit pas et ce
sera déjà bénéfique
malheureusement nous ne vivons pas dans
le monde des bisounours
il a de multiples obstacles qui nous
bloque à l'intérieur de notre zone de
confort
premièrement
le regard des autres
on a tous une réputation soit à
conserver soit à construire et le
jugement des autres fait peur surtout
quand il vient des personnes de notre
entourage en attendant ça très souvent
faire ce que les autres attendent de
nous plutôt que ce qu'on a réellement
envie de faire
ensuite
il y a la peur de l'inconnu de se mettre
en difficulté dans quelque chose qui va
peut-être même pas forcément nous plaire
et puis vient la peur de l'échec qui
pour moi est intimement lié avec un
manque de confiance en soi pour mon
domaine par exemple je vois les grands
humoristes de ce monde et je me dis mais
c'est pas possible ils sont nés comme ça
ça paraît tellement facile pour eux
et puis ya aussi une question d'ego là
derrière on n'a pas envie de se louper
et constater nos faiblesses
ensuite
il y a le sur perfectionnisme qui me
concerne tout particulièrement
donc ça peut être avantageux dans une
certaine mesure mais ça devient
réellement problématique quand vous être
parfait
ça incite clairement à la
procrastination par exemple et puis pour
terminer le découragement face un trop
gros travail on a l'impression qu'on n'y
arrivera jamais
fall a maintenant que j'ai bien
décourager tout le monde on va pouvoir
remonter la pente ensemble tous ces
obstacles sont contrebalancés par les
avantages qu'ils résultent de sortir de
sa zone de confort
il faut écouter ce que les autres ont à
nous apporter mais pas se laisser
bouffer par le jugement constant et ceux
qui essayeront de vous tirer vers le bas
et puis aller vers l'inconnu c'est le
meilleur moyen d'apprendre de découvrir
et d'augmenter son ouverture d'esprit
les échecs sont possibles mais faut bien
penser que c'est grâce à eux qu'on
s'améliore et qu'on fera mieux la
prochaine fois et puis pour mon domaine
les grands humoristes de ce monde ben il
faut bien que j'imagine qu'ils ont tous
commencé à quelque part qui se sont déjà
plantés et qu'ils ont dû beaucoup
travaillé pour en arriver là qu'il
perfectionnisme oui il faut que je me
donne à 100% il y mettre du coeur mais
il faut aussi que je sois un peu
indulgents avec moi même je peux pas
être parfait et heureusement imaginer un
monde peuplé de rodger federer ce serait
vraiment pas drôle
et le travail peut être énorme
mais je pense qu'il faut faire les
choses une après les autres une fois
j'arrivais pas à commencer un travail
et c'est là que mon papa est venu vers
moi d'ailleurs je lui souhaite un bon
anniversaire aujourd'hui
et il m'a dit
maintenant tu arrêtes ton cirque étude
met à travailler
alors dit comme ça ça sonne plus comme
une menace qu'un conseil
mais ça m'a fait prendre conscience que
le plus dur c'est souvent de commencer
vous dit peut-être non mais se prend
pour qui ce jeu pour nous donner des
leçons de vie
et je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous ces conseils sont beaucoup plus
facile à dire qu'à faire moi-même
j'essaye de les appliquer au quotidien
mais j'ai échoué très souvent
je vais pas vraiment confiance en moi et
j'ai failli mourir de stress avant de
venir ici
comme quoi c'est un combat perpétuel
contre soi au fond il faut juste trouver
son équilibre personnel et savoir
s'écouter l' envie de sortir de sa zone
varie selon l'âge la période de vie la
personnalité ou encore si vous avez
trouvé la motivation qui vous anime ou
non
alors je ne peux que vous conseiller
d'agrandir votre zone de confort au vu
de tout ce que ça m'a apporté et des
avantages cités avant mais si vous vous
sentez bien dans votre zone et que vous
avez la liberté qu'il vous faut faut pas
culpabiliser de ne pas vouloir en sortir
j'en vois certains qui font des gros
yeux tout va bien je suis même très
content pour vous
par contre si vous ressentez un mal être
que vous n'êtes que vous n'êtes plus en
accord avec ce que vous êtes ou ce que
vous vivez
eh bien vous savez ce que vous avez à
faire n'hésitez plus faites le pas le
grand plongeon pour trouver votre
équilibre personnel
et demain je reçois des messages de
patrons énervé art super votre
conférence mon collaborateur a quitté
l'entreprise pour se lancer dans le
commerce de betteraves en ligne dans le
sud de l'asie
on sait jamais
mais regardez-moi je fais partie des
millions d'exemple de gens qui sont
sortis de leur zone de confort et à qui
ça a profité
je suis devant vous ce soir à l'endroit
où je me sens le plus vivant la scène et
je crois que j'ai même le droit un petit
apéritif gratuit après donc ça vaut
vraiment la peine
ne vous laissez pas décourager c'est
votre liberté si vous avez envie de
faire quelque chose allez-y
la vie est trop courte pour attendre
si vous voulez verser une larme c'est
maintenant merci beaucoup de m'avoir
écouté
[Applaudissements]